Some say that a movie gets made three times once when it's written again,
when it's shot and finally when it's edited,
but sometimes it feels like we overvalue the first two steps and undervalued the
last one in film criticism, we seem to focus more on the writers and directors,
and we especially love it when one person does both,
but that still leaves out one third of the story.
And this phenomenon is nothing new
editors weren't even given credit for their work and early silent films.
Back then people saw cutting film as a menial job that required no creativity as
a result. It was labeled as a job suitable for women and by extension not worth
mentioning,
but as filmmaking grew more sophisticated editing quickly became a crucial part
of the creative process while still remaining largely overlooked.
And perhaps the most important of them all is the legendary DD Allen,
Bonnie and Clyde is one of the most important movies of all time that involved
many influential filmmakers like Arthur, Penn, Warren Beatty,
and Francois Truffaut, but some film analysis, overlooks editors like DD Allen.
It is not an overstatement to say that her editing changed films forever.
And that's why she became the first editor in film history to be credited with
her own title card for her work on Bonnie and Clyde.
So let's dive into the work of DDL and see what it shows us about the gendered
history of Hollywood film editing,
and who really makes the movie to really understand how Alan appended film
language.
We have to look at the generation of film editors who came before her in 1938,
film editor,
Margaret Booth wrote the cutter an essay about the role of a film editor.
She describes the techniques she learns that we now take for granted things like
establishing shots,
using closeups to stress and emotional moment and cutting tools smoothly through
different shots. She established an artistry to film editing.
It was no longer just assembling film,
but finding the rhythm of a scene in her words,
cutting at its best produces a film flowing so smoothly that the audience thinks
only of the entertainment and gives no thought to the mechanics that went to
create it.
Much of her early work in film was uncredited and she notes that apart from
editing filmmaking was a masculine affair.
She even implies this insight in her word choice. On the first page,
she refers to an editor as he or she, but a director as only he,
she collaborated with DW Griffith and other influential early directors whose
films created the playbook by which all other editors worked,
the more invisible the editor, the better.
Long shot to shot single single.
There was almost a formulaic way of presenting film.
That style remains the exclusive method of film editing in Hollywood until DDL
Allen appended at all.
No, nobody else over your shoulder and say, you're here.
Why do you need that?
From the start of her career, Alan, couldn't help, but break rules.
She got her start editing television commercials,
a medium that naturally disobeyed Hollywood standards commercials needed to
communicate a lot of information in a short period of time.
So they favored striking fast paced,
cutting over the slower paced Hollywood style.
And she didn't shy away from these techniques.
When she transitions to editing feature films,
Alan's in your face and rhythmic style sent shock waves throughout the industry.
She made a name for herself by turning Hollywood editing tropes on their head
rather than a biding by the industry standard of using a dissolve to signal the
passage of time. Alan preferred to do the exact opposite. Instead,
she would cut harshly from one moment to another. At the start of her career,
she defaulted to Hollywood norms, but in the 1960s,
she experimented with using a harsh cut to imply the passage of time.
Instead of a dissolve by the seventies, her cuts grew more daring.
And in this scene, she jumps to later moments in the night.
Hey man, I didn't really at the top.
And by the eighties, her cuts jumps to new days entirely.
[Inaudible].
This technique puts the editor in the forefront and calls attention to the cuts.
But instead of disrupting the film,
it lends a rhythm to these scenes and it gives more information to the viewer in
a shorter period of time.
Soon after her films received a claim editors throughout the industry,
mimicked Allen's signature, fast paced editing,
and her techniques became commonplace.
Another example of an editing technique that she made standard was pre lapping
audio from the next scene into the scene proceeding it.
You can't haul it down my rainbow.
These are techniques so widely used now, but almost seems mundane.
But at the time it was another example of her rule-breaking style at the start
of Serpico, she uses it to great effect. We hear the siren,
the rhythmic beating of the windshield and the labored breathing.
Before we even see a character on screen,
she communicated the tense tone of the film immediately, and it works.
This opening challenge has several established editing convention.
So you said you always start with a long shot.
Then you move in to an over shoulder or a group shot. And he said,
and you never changed that order. And somehow or other,
I was breaking that rule constantly.
Instead of opening on a wide shot of the city or even a medium shot of the car
out chose to open the film on a close-up of ALPA Chino's bleeding face.
She replaced a spatial establishing shot with a tonal establishing shot.
And that combined with the pre lapping sounds primacy audience for the tents and
unsettling tone of the film it's innovations like hers that have become so
ingrained in film language that we still see her influence everywhere Allen's
preference to start a scene,
even a film on a close-up of a character reveal something very important about
her style, her focus on performance.
She was an actors editor and often kept in mistakes as long as they gave
authenticity to the scene.
Okay.
Editing was no doubt in your face and never sacrifice the moments the camera
captured.
We can see her ability to capture the moment in the famous advocacy in dog day
afternoon, the editing is stylistic and the cuts speed up over time,
but she still takes the time to hold on Pachino se paces nervously and considers
his situation, or to cut back to his partners, nervous, look inside the bank.
Considering the scale of this scene with interiors, exteriors,
several characters and even aerial shots,
it would have been no surprise if it had to sacrifice these intimate moments,
but Alan's care to build naturally and focus on character rather than spectacle
makes it such an electric moment.
These innovations are why she became the first editor, woman,
or man to receive an opening title card exclusively for her in Bonnie and Clyde
in a position at originally left the female editor, invisible her style,
not only enhanced visual storytelling,
but it clearly shows the influence and editor has on the final film
by the 1980s, DD Alan's talent became well-established. And later in her career,
she had a role in more than just post-production while editing for the breakfast
club writer, director, John Hughes referred to her as his film teacher,
she would regularly contribute during filming.
She was there in person with all her equipment.
She would walk onto the set and tell John,
if there was a shot or an angle she could already see when she would cut
together. What we were doing, that she would need.
You can see her influence by comparing shot coverage and the breakfast club with
Hughes's previous film, 16 candles, for example,
both films had a weird girl listening in on the main conversation,
but in 16 candles, she's only filmed in the wide shot.
And because of that limitation,
her performance doesn't really land in her scene with the better shot coverage
and the breakfast club Didi Allen had much more to work with.
Very interesting section of work that she did on that film,
which I never thought I was going to use that way,
but she was quite enchanted and she did. So it turned out and I used a lot of.
Like her previous work. The breakfast club is a feat in editing.
Alan cuts between up to six characters at once and it never feels confusing or
unnatural.
This film proves how an editor can make or break a film and makes us realize
that he films vision comes from more than the writer director.
She had a say in how it was shot. And according to Hughes,
she changed the way he cut pictures forever.
The editor he said is the single most underrated person in the whole business,
but collaboration is not always that smooth for some first time, male directors,
their ego can become a problem.
The worst problem I've had with directors are young writers on their first
picture. They were.
Doing my first movie.
The only thing I knew is I wanted a female editor because I just felt
a female editor would be more nurturing to the movie. And to me,
they wouldn't be trying to shove their agenda. Or when they're backs.
Bottles with me,
Tarantino had difficulty compromising with his editor in his early films.
The date scene in pulp fiction was originally much longer,
but editor Sally Mankey fought hard to trim it down constantly going back and
forth with him. We do that.
For eight months. So intense. I see him more than once.
But like other great female editors,
Sally had be passionate and raw talent to convince her director to change the
film.
So later, I guess I put enough pressure on him to convince them,
let me try it the other way. Very often they wait.
If you watch the deleted scenes at the diner and imagine Terentino's original
even longer scene, it's pretty clear that Sally's input saved it.
After her tragic death in 2010 Tarantino called her his only truly genuine
collaborator.
And one can only imagine how much stronger the pacing of his postings glorious
bastards films would have been. If Sally was there to make them with him.
Tarantino was one of the countless male directors who owe their success in part
to a brilliant female editor.
The idea that a singular historically male director is the sole visionary for a
film comes into question when considering female editors like Sally Mankey,
Margaret Booth and Deedee Allen,
these women had a lot more creative control than most people are aware of.
One word or two sequences. In the beginning. He said,
you just stay on your own.
And throughout film history,
the editor was the only feminine point of view available to the director.
Margaret Booth felt that directors often preferred her over a man of equal
ability and experienced because the director could get her unique perspective as
a woman, even 100 years ago,
female film editors had a say in how movies got made.
The very nature of an editor's work dooms the profession to be constantly under
appreciated. The majority of the work takes place alone in a dark room.
And it's unfortunate that this environment was the only one that a woman had a
set far removed from every other aspect of filmmaking.
There's a cruel irony to the fact that an editor is successful.
If her work is invisible in the final product and to filmmaking legends,
like Alan goes so underappreciated one, can't help,
but wonder what other voices we miss when we say a film was made by a singular
writer director. So the next time you watch a Scorsese film or a Tarantino film,
ask yourself who else made
DD Alan's work and to the work of countless other women in film often remains
invisible to the average movie goer,
especially when you only focus on who's producing,
writing and directing blockbuster films. Meanwhile,
women are dominating other less high profile parts of the film industry like
documentary filmmaking,
four out of the five Oscar nominated films for best documentary in 2020 had
female directors or co-directors documentary films featured legendary editors,
writers and producers that like DD Allen are often overlooked.
But with curiosity, stream's newly expanded library.
There are thousands of documentary titles that will have you in all of the
non-fiction John rhe, like the history of food,
a critically acclaimed documentary about the science history and cultural impact
of food over time,
which has produced and co-written and directed by Sarah Venable burns.
What better way to spend your quarantine days than to expand your mind?
And there's more to CuriosityStream has partnered with Nebula,
the creator owned streaming service that I actually helped build along with a
bunch of other creators, you know,
in love there we're posting all of our content ad free,
as well as creating Nebula originals, like the ongoing series, working titles.
It's a series analyzing TV title sequences with episodes by Patrick.
Each Willem's just right and yours truly,
and nebulous subscriptions are automatically included with an annual
subscription to curiosity stream, go to curiosity, stream.com/.
Now you see it and enter the promo code.
Now you see it when prompted during the signup process,
thanks to curiosity stream for sponsoring and thanks to you,
our patrons for your support. If you want to support our work directly,
join our Patrion for exclusive benefits. Thanks for watching.